let's take that up with uh mr eric
weinstein so uh eric has a tweet thread
saying
essentially that no one really believes
in woke ideology
so i had a conversation this a
conversation about this last week but
let's let's read what eric says
and i'm going to say this i agree with
him but uh i'll read eric says hyper
unpopular view i don't think a single
person on earth
believes ideology any soul who truly
quote
identifies as an eagle would be
instantly eliminated by testing the
hypothesis
i think he's implying the person would
like you know jump off a building
but i don't know who enterprise is an
eagle so but says a person who believed
two plus two equals five would be unable
to file taxes
that's a real good point if you're gonna
make an argument about this
a semantic argument about integers and
what determines two plus two equaling
four or five
how do you function on a day-to-day
basis but are we done
he says get woke go broke is nowhere
near extreme enough truly believing in
wokeness could get you jailed or killed
my hypothesis is that every single soul
espousing wokeness critical theory
etc is doing so disingenuously and
without exception
that is why it can't be defeated by
reason wokeness is reveling in the idea
that it makes no sense
the only ones believing it are those
fighting it further this is why
inclusion
is at its core a strategy because the
remedy for wokeness wasting the energy
of
the developed world by boring us to
death is to exclude it
not on the base of it being wrong but
because the saboteur must always be
excluded from civic life
let me give other positions so extreme
they are primophasia disingenuous
crypto toxic bitcoin maxillism hyper
conservatives
we need a strong defense in a dangerous
world but also all taxes theft etc
all of these are parasitic on someone
else being the adult
i agree with him that the woke do not
believe
any of their ideology and i don't
i don't know of anybody who identifies
as an eagle so i don't know what that's
a reference to
but i understand the point he's trying
to make to a certain degree
i do think the two plus two equaling
equaling five is a good point to be made
because they're there is it is a hill
they're absolutely willing to die on
where where now you have i think like an
mit
mathematician coming out making a video
explaining how tuples
could equal five and if that's an
assumption you could make
then at what point in your taxes do you
say i think this one's going to be a
four and that one's going to be a five
well the couple of things one is that
because because the what we're calling
the wokeness
initiative i'm i added the word
initiative
the initiative of what we're calling
wokeness is
destructive and subversive
they want to live in a world where they
can say to the irs
oh no i say it's five and to say i'm
wrong makes you a racist
right so it gives them the ability to
determine when it is true or not to
benefit themselves so his argument that
no that won't work because
you'll go to the he wants to be able to
go out into the bank
and change get changed for a 10 and come
back with a hundred
okay that's that's part of the goal but
i think there's another problem here
which is that
he tends to hang around with very smart
people like you and me
but we know more dumb people than he
does there are a lot of really dumb
people
michael malus midwifes not even that
dumb
well they're actually smart midwifes
smart enough to
simulate high intelligence but in fact
to be
mediocre thinkers who
i believe are buying it and they are
because we're underestimating the power
the marvelous wonderful power of
cognitive dissonance
it doesn't add up it will come to we all
read 1984
you come around eventually to believing
that
the the right thing because it
lets your brain relax the social
pressure is off
yes i am a racist you know what i've
said a million times
and no one ever retweets it because
they're afraid
if all these white chicks and they're
mostly chicks
hating themselves for being white hating
themselves for being
hating whiteness and wish if they woke
up
black they would walk
right out the window they would kill
themselves they're racists
they would they're the biggest racist in
the world
and if you disagree with me you're
you're
you are a racist because
if i'm right if i'm wrong then you're
telling me no you're not you're raised
if i'm wrong then there is not
actually systemic racism and if i'm
right that there is systemic racism
we see that the systemic racism makes
hypocrites out of all these people
bemoaning their whiteness
pretty good huh ron called me for the
win well yeah
i i don't think that uh the way i
described it last week is i don't think
they actually believe this stuff but
it's impossible to believe two
contradictory things at the same time
unless of course we're suggesting
they're suffering from cognitive
dissonance
these are the kind of people that will
say the sky is blue and the sky is green
to your face in the same sentence
they can't simultaneously well do what
you say
say that they are racists and that
racists are bad
but they are good that's just i'll tell
you this you ever see these videos where
it's like a white guy's like on tick
tock and he's like telling everybody how
racist he is
if anybody ever came up to me a white
person and started talking about
critical race theory
or critical theory and then said that
they were a racist i'd be like
and now you can stop talking because
you're a racist and it's time for you to
sit down to listen
congratulations your own ideology says
shut up
sit down but nobody does this no you
know one of the things that really
bothers me is i keep hearing about
people quitting their jobs because
they're being trained critical race
through things like this
and i'm like so what you're telling me
is that they your workplace is violating
the civil rights act of 1964 is that
title
seven i think and you just quit you see
here's the problem
these leftists will use anything to
claim as racism
and they'll get away with it how about
this we have this story out of uh out of
seattle that i'll just pull up
reparations fee to be charged for white
people at seattle gay pride event
well we're now hearing the seattle human
rights commission has dismissed the
complaint
saying that well you know you got to
look at history and recognize that this
is actually okay
all right so they're willing to look at
overt racial discrimination
and say it's not okay now i understand
this is a challenge
the eeoc may be full of woke individuals
who refuse to accept your complaints
but if you work it if you work at a
company the moment someone says the word
white anything you can now claim
they're being racist it's their rules
for example
here's what here's what i've said on the
show before if they say we're gonna have
a discussion on
white privilege you just stop them and
say excuse me did you just bring
all these people in in here to learn
about white
benefits like why why it's better to be
white do you think that's okay to like
why don't we have a conversation about
non-whiteness why did you think
whiteness was the appropriate subject
you're racist you're white supremacist
you're having a clan meeting no matter
what they say the moment they say
anything related to race
you can claim racism the right doesn't
do this
and perhaps because they think they're
fighting fair but
i'll tell you this you know if you think
you're playing you know let me slow down
i'll do a different analogy
we're playing a game monopoly we're
watching the other side pull bills out
of the out of the bank
in our front of our faces and we go hey
wait you can't do that
and they're like yeah i can and you go
okay and you keep playing and then
you're like why do i keep losing i don't
understand how did you have so much
money to buy boardwalk and park place
and put hotels on it
i don't know i guess i'll never figure
it out but i did see you taking all that
money you're not supposed to do
oh well that sounds like the discussion
about the um
election audits in what way what do you
mean
why do you why are you suppressing votes
by doing election audits
because of these you saw oh there was
the you see the colorado woman
she was like we're banning fraud yeah
that was funny because i was like
colorado no one asked you like you're
not one of the states
so i liken it to like you're sitting in
a meeting and someone just goes i didn't
fart
and then you're like no one said
anything dude
but are we in for a surprise in the next
few minutes yeah all right a few seconds
people are gonna take a notice and then
it's like
if someone just randomly blurted that
out you'd be like uh where'd that come
from
did you fart like why did you say that
so that's you know
she blurts it out but um but anyway in
in reference to uh
you're talking about a level of courage
that the vast majority of people don't
have
conservatives anti-establishment the
right regular people
well then the left is full of not
regular people
no it takes no courage to follow
the current that has been
cut for you by
the leaders in culture then it should
take no courage for someone who opposes
this to just ride the wave
and say that's racist don't say it again
i'm writing it down
do you think this this hr let me tell
you this you got an hr director
middle-aged white woman and she's given
a brochure about diversity
initiatives and then you start huffing
and puffing about how she's saying
racist things
do you think this woman's going to you
think she's going to keep going risk her
job
or do you think she's going to be like i
don't know are you white or black
it doesn't matter oh yes it does i don't
think it does oh wait
the people leading the charge like rob
and d'angelo are white and they're the
ones coming up making the demands and
they're getting their way
are they yes yeah that she's getting
paid tens of thousands of dollars to
teach at universities
and her applied critical race theory is
appearing in schools across the country
right she's getting it she's getting
everything she wants no no but
to protest against her
you can't be white no no no no no no no
no
you can grift and here it is used
properly
you can grift from this
this you know system this ecosystem
of grievance and fiction and whatever it
is
and be white but you can't push back
against it and be why you could so hold
on let me break this down
if a white person like robin deangelo
says
this system is it is racist she's
allowed to do it
and then if you say literally the same
thing you can't
if you're white i'm not sure i follow if
i say literally the same thing
i i can say it but it's the next thing
that i say that you're talking about
no no so like you're you're in a
diversity meeting
and you have a white woman speaking at
your hr meeting and you accuse her of
being racist
try it on me try okay so you just said
to me your your little
magic formula you think's gonna solve
this problem
mr coleman i don't understand why you're
allowed to talk about
about white privilege that makes it
sound like it's better to be white no
i didn't say to say that say say why are
you having us having a meeting centered
around white people
why are white people because white
people are the problem
so when people are dominating white
people have dominated the cultural and
historical so you're a white supremacist
on the contrary i'm going to report you
to the eeoc if you say one more word you
bigot
i am not gonna sit here and listen to
you talk about your white supremacist
views in front of me and after
everything my family's been through
say it one more time and i will go to
your boss sir
say it one more time you white
supremacist the mere fact that i'm
writing it down the words white
supremacist
and then you go to the eeoc and here's
what you say
okay so you're we're now going to just
do like on a tv show and just show the
next scene
after the extremely unlikely stuff
happens
fade to the next okay i i think you you
misunderstand that uh i'm saying
you think that see you what you
demonstrated was
nothing but courage you demonstrated
that you're willing to
being tim pool and having a lot of
confidence and having a certain station
in life
and being a guy with a certain amount of
testosterone that you're prepared
to really push this and to try to
intimidate
a midwit a professional midwit
most people won't do that perhaps i've
done it and i have one on multiple
occasions you're tim poole
so when i when i was making 10 bucks an
hour
working for political uh fundraising
organizations
i uh or i should say when i did
fundraising i've sued two organizations
and one doing exactly as i've described
that's why you're timpled today perhaps
so if people just use the system as it
existed they'd start winning
the problem people like you but most
people aren't like you take it from me
because i'm more like you than i'm like
the other people
the left is doing this does the left
have more courageous people than the
right
no then why do they keep doing it why
are they the ones to file eeoc
complaints and win
because the eeoc is owned by them
because the press is owned by them
because the courts are owned by them
because the academia is owned by them
they had a system in place
especially in academia and in the
corporate world it turns out to
everyone's surprise no one was ready for
this
and as well as the attorneys general
they worked their way
very very brilliantly into a number of
very
very important institutions in american
life
the academia project goes back already
before even before i was born
but the fruit of that has been
that in all the sectors where ideas
are filtered for acceptability
the left owns them let me ask you
something
no if if somebody's not going to let you
ask me something if somebody went to the
eeoc and said
my hr director made a bunch of racist
comments and i asked them to stop and
they refused what do you think the eeoc
would say
what were the comments i'm not going to
repeat them
i mean it was disparaging things about
race they were talking about how races
are better than others
mr poole please when you have a chance
when you when you cool down a little bit
write down the comments for us because
we can't proceed unless we have a
detailed explanation of what was
made and also give us the names of
everyone else who was at the meeting
well it was to describe what the what
these comments were
and we will then send it over to the
very big warehouse over there where they
keep the ark of the covenant
and we'll get back to you as soon as
possible
why is it that when i went to these
agencies on more than one on two
occasions
and did exactly as i described it worked
because you've got balls i don't know
that's that's irrelevant
i'm talking about when when was it this
was
13 years ago 13 and 14 years ago 4013
years ago
so much has changed in the last 13 years
tim
so much has changed it is mind-boggling
you're advocating for people to not use
the legal
no system as it stands no make an
attempt
far be it for me to do that i'm i i'm a
schmuck
who like you keeps knocking his head
against the wall expecting a different
result
i'm all in favor of that so then we
shouldn't but you're asking the
you're asking the empirical question is
why isn't everyone doing it because
there aren't so many schmucks like
coleman and poole
here's the question why is the left
doing it
i rewind academia courts that's not
answering the question
i say it is answering the question so
leftists know that because they
inherently control all the institutions
they can file a complaint and win and
because conservatives are demoralized
they won't even try
yeah okay now now that we've recognized
that conservatives should say oh okay
i'll go out and try
yeah problem solved there you go
ron and tim you've done it thanks for
coming
when i went to uh these meetings they
didn't ask me for a verbatim
recollection of what happened because
that's impossible to produce
i said to the best of my understanding
they made comments about this that or
otherwise
and that won't happen now it won't
happen now
companies have changed not in 13 years
not in three years in two years
a close family member of mine worked in
microsoft
and said you know as big corporations go
they have their kind of mandatory
mealy mouth mouthing you know stuff
about diversity but it's pretty
cool i got a feeling things are really
done here
in the last two years it turned
into a nightmare in the last two
years corporate america is cowed
the the judiciary is counted things
things have changed a great deal but
i'll tell you something else tim
this is a related phenomenon
i had to leave two law firms in a row
because i was taking on cases
where my partner said well you're
representing
a side that has a really bad reputation
gavin mcinnis
or gab they're associated with nazis
no no i'm taking on those cases because
they're being wrongly associated with
nazis
i'm trying to vindicate their
reputations
yeah but you know we have we have
interns
and we have vendors and we have clients
some of them are holocaust survivors
some of them
are um you know uh
you know we give money to the to this uh
you know uh affirmative action program
we just can't and you know i understand
if you've got a law firm that you've
built up over 50 or 100 years
and you're an equity partner in that
organization and
you have a stake in it and ron coleman
wants to sweep in
and be the guy who's gonna
show the world that gavin mcinnes isn't
isn't a racist or an extremist or show
the world that gab
is entitled to sue uh google because
they are monopolist
it's not well maybe ron you might want
to do that you might even be right but
it's working very well for the rest of
us to not do that
and we can do without your revenue like
you we like what you're practicing
thank god i'm with harmy dylan now and
she takes on not the craziest cases but
relatively crazy cases
because they're not so crazy that's so
that's the the analog to what we're
talking about here is
is that it's an uphill battle but yes we
have to do it
we have to do it so i'm curious like
this these firms you describe you know
they're very worried about
the threats or accusations couldn't
anyone of any political persuasion just
weaponize that by claiming i'm gonna
accuse you of it what are you gonna do
about it
i mean you don't say it like that
obviously but what if one of these
interns
was you know a far right and they were
like you know what
i'm sick of it my pronouns are
flabberdooflabidi
don't use my pronouns and i'll file i
mean in new york for instance it's a
human rights violation with a fine of up
to 250 000
for willful misuse of someone's pronouns
right that's unconstitutional and
eventually that that will be
that will be thrown out on first
amendment grounds but it'll need
challenging and which means it'll need a
legal case
thanks for checking out this clip from
the tim cast irl podcast
if you want to see the full show come
back to this channel youtube.com
tim cast irl monday through friday at
8pm where you can leave comments
and super chat and we actually will read
your comments
on the show don't forget to like share
subscribe and if you want exclusive
members only content segments you can't
get anywhere else
go to timcast.com become a member and we
even have full bonus episodes
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time
you